[Musique]
cent ans après marcel proust c'est jean
paul dubois qui reçoit le prix goncourt
pour tous les hommes n'habite pas le
monde de la même façon et qui veulent en
même temps le prix à amélie nothomb ben
déjà nommé en 1999 pour stupeur et
tremblements et en 2007 pour ni d'eve ni
d'adam
c'était donc la troisième fois que la
romancière étaient concours abl le prix
goncourt ne lui sied pas où amélie
nothomb mais est elle maudite
il semblerait que son 28e roman ne
correspond pas tout à fait aux
stéréotypes du concours c'est pas un
mauvais roman soif au contraire je pense
que la plupart des critiques ont été on
était un peu souffler qu'elle soit un
peu dans l'audace qu'elles osent
utiliser un personnage historique comme
j'ai écrit c'était culotté
d'ailleurs les lecteurs de nos taux
habituel on était là lire comme
d'habitude mais elle a gagné des
lecteurs en plus peut-être des cathos
qui se sont dit tiens on écrit sur jésus
qu'est ce qu'elle peut bien faire
peut-être on a considéré que notons
c'est un problème elle est archi archi
connu est ce que c'est pâques too much
selon une étude de l'institut gfk pour
livres hebdo sur la période 2014 2018
un goncourt s'écoule en moyenne
367 1000 exemplaires devant le goncourt
des lycéens et le renaudot
soit d'amélie nothomb ben s'est déjà
écoulé à 146 mille exemplaires alors
peut-être que le jury a considéré
qu'elle n'avait pas besoin de ce coup de
pouce supplémentaire pour vendre son
rang logiquement si on voulait et c'est
un peu lisse guide est couronné
quelqu'un qui est la reine du box office
il fallait couronné notons ça permettait
d'avoir un gros concours et ça
permettait de faire plaisir aux
libraires elle a peut-être pâti
justement de son de sa grande notoriété
ce qui est assez cruel puisque
finalement depuis 20 ans elle tire le
marché vers le haut avec des vents très
importante si elle est passée sans doute
de 400 milliards 25 ans à cent mille
aujourd'hui mais où 1 140 mais elle a
peut-être curieusement parlons trop
notoriété trop doha trop de présence et
un livre qu'on peut juger clivant si on
considère que écrire un roman sur
jésus-christ ça peut être client
[Musique]